let me tell you a story about a guy
named william johnson who's a prominent
white nationalist and a big league
supporter of Donald Trump's campaign he
is now paying for a robocall ad that is
targeting the anti-trump conservative
presidential candidate Evan McMullen in
Utah I don't want to tell you anything
about the ad I'm just gonna play it for
you this is a robo call because it's
it's truly amazing it makes me feel like
we're in I don't know the 70s or before
hello my name is William Johnson I'm a
farmer and a white nationalist I make
this call against Evan McMullen and in
support of Donald Trump yes Evan
McMullen is an open borders amnesty
supporter evan has two mommies
his mother is a lesbian married to
another woman Evan is okay with that
indeed Evan supports the Supreme Court
ruling legalizing gay marriage Evan is
over 40 years old and is not married and
doesn't even have a girlfriend
I believe Evan is a closeted homosexual
don't vote for Evan McMullen vote for
Donald Trump he will respect all women
and be a president we can all be proud
of ya I paid for this ad for the
American national super-pac guys Evan
McMullen doesn't even have a girlfriend
and his mom's are lesbians and he's gay
so vote for Trump now Johnson was asked
well what evidence do you have for these
claims by The Daily Beast and he said
well Wikipedia mentions the story about
Evan McMullen's mom and if you google
him there's a lot of other people who
think he's gay also none of this is
accurate but the I I don't even care
obviously the the white nationalist Pro
Trump robocall I don't think anybody in
our audience expect it to be
particularly fact-based but it's just
the idea that you do a call and number
one you openly mention hey I'm a white
nationalist maybe you would worry that
that might turn a few people off
although if it's focused in Utah I know
the Mirman Mormon Church only recently
said that black people are equal to
white people so maybe there's something
to that but the whole don't vote for him
because he's gay thing does that appeal
to anybody anymore I know there were
homophobes but I don't know very few
people and it's funny how this kind of
puts you in a box where you have to say
oh he's not gay and yeah his mom's
remarried to a lesbian woman but he
doesn't agree with that I mean there's
nothing wrong with any of that right
this is too nuts even
the Trump campaign because they said oh
we don't want anything to do with this
that we didn't coordinate this we reject
the support of white supremacists
william johnson when the Trump campaign
says it's actually a little much for us
you know this guy's over the top right
kind of like when Al Queda was like
we're kind of scared of Isis but but
yeah I am I don't know I do feel like
that the homophobic angle definitely
appeals to a lot of people even do you
think an eye in Utah in particular or
just nationally I think nationally maybe
even Utah particularly I don't really
have that much data about homophobic in
Utah but I'm positive that it will
appeal to a large number of people this
type of nonsense that we are seeing
should be relegated to the nooks and
crannies of obscure corners of the
internet but instead it's a robo call
going to nearly 200,000 people paid for
by a white nationalist
accusing one candidate of being gay as a
reason not to vote for him I I guess I
mean I'm not really commending the Trump
campaign because it's sort of obvious
that you don't want support from
homophobic white nationalists in the
United States on balance although it
will appeal to somebody but the Trump
campaign at least did the right thing as
bad as things are for them Pat in saying
this is not for us right but there's
still gonna be the beneficiaries of this
ad right it's just how like when Trump
decided not to denounce David Duke right
away and yeah I mean he was still kind
of giving a wink in the nod to say oh
yeah I do kind of support what he's
saying when you denounce him after a
week you've already given the wink and
the nod to the people who've liked that
endorsement and then you're still
getting on paper the fact that you don't
actually want the endorsement you might
have noticed months ago that I had this
very very bright metal watch that I
would wear on the show and that's a
watch that I have had for I think at
this point something like 13 or 14 years
and I took it off a couple months ago
and was just sort of done with it and
was thinking of getting a new watch and
one of the companies that I was looking
at that I really like is movement
watches and before I pulled the trigger
because I take months to make any buying
decision anybody who knows me knows that
a movement watch is actually approached
us and said hey we'd like to sponsor
some episodes of the David Pakman show
we'd like
to send you a free watch and and we want
to be involved and that is now the watch
that people have seen me wearing
movement watches the back story is
similar to the David Pakman show in that
it was two broke college kids who
started movement watches and the idea
was watches that are nice very often
cost four or five hundred dollars at a
department store instead movement
watches start at $95 they have grown
their business much like we've grown the
David Pakman show with the help of
crowdfunding like IndieGoGo they've done
that and we've done that and for our
audience they have actually set up a
promo code if you go to MU n VMT watches
dot-com slash Pakman you will get 15%
off of your order plus free shipping
plus free returns if you decide that you
want to exchange or return your watch
check it out I love this watch I get
compliments on it everywhere I go and I
want you to check them out as well go to
M V M T watches dot-com slash Pakman
that's PA k ma n 15% off